- [Voiceover] We have three
plus blank is equal to 10.
So pause the video and try to figure out
what the blank is.
What do I have to add
to three to get to 10?
So you've had a go at it.
Now let's see if we can do this together.
So over here, I have three of these,
I guess you could say purple,
these purple pinkish circles
and I have 10 boxes.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, ten.
So one way to think about it is,
how many more circles do
I need to add to fill up
all of the boxes?
Well, let's just count that together.
I need to add one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven to fill up all 10 boxes.
So three plus what is equal 10?
Well, three plus one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
is equal to 10.
Let's do one more of these.
So now I have six plus
blank is equal to 10.
So again, try to pause the video
and see if you can figure
out what the blank is.
What do I need to add to six to get to 10?
Let's do it together.
So we now have one, two,
three, four, five, six circles.
We have 10 boxes here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
So we just have to think
about how many more circles
do we need to fill up all
the boxes to get to 10
because we already have six filled in.
Well, we need one, two,
three, four to get to 10.
So let's just fill that in.
Six plus four is equal to 10,
or we could say even that
four plus six is equal to 10, either way.